my name is jealous vamoose and the
general manager of the center for
recovering encourage children in Brazil
it's called brain st. ridiculous only
because you now and I'd like to speak
about the first question which is what
is the biggest impact resource in Latin
America I think the biggest important
resource is our is our human capital we
have massive resources in human beings
but we are not investing enough in
education of quality oh all sorts of
education and even in for instance in
Brazil now the excess of to education is
almost universal the quality of the
education we are offering to people it's
not enough there are many NGOs and many
profit business trying to do something
about it but I think it for the amount
of problem we should work together more
integrated to deal with this with this
problem